my mom brought some gifts over for
mother's day
but i'm really confused mom why all the
crying faces
there was plenty of love to go around
with the kardashians on mother's day
well this morning was interesting the
special day was also the second birthday
of psalm west
kim and kanye's youngest child i feel
like having four is so much more
zen on sunday she shared this adorable
pic of her baby boy to instagram
and wrote quote i can't even describe
his smile
and sweetness that everyone just feels
when they are with him
she added quote all of your cousins and
siblings love you so much
you really are the joy of our crew chloe
shared some videos from her nephew's
second birthday party
including psalm with a number two pinata
which rob's daughter dream
also took a swing at a dream
come on dre and there was plenty of
kardashian cousin time
chloe posted herself in a bouncy house
with her daughter true
stormy webster and st west now since the
baby's here everyone gets along
everyone loves each other i'm rolling
with it and every kardashian and jenner
felt the love from their favorite
momager
my mom brought some gifts over for
mother's day
but i'm really confused kim shared this
moment to her instagram stories
where chris jokingly laid down some
truths about being a mother to the
famous family
mom why all the crying faces
on your gifts that's just how you wanted
to tag them because you guys have been a
pain in the ass
for 40 something years but i do love
being a mother
but chris wasn't left out of the special
day tributes she posted this video of
flowers she received from her son rob
you guys cannot believe the size
of these fabulous peonies
rob you are incredible
thank you so much for my gorgeous
gorgeous flowers they're just
insane they're so big that we had to put
them on the floor
chris also shared flowers gifted from
kim kylie scott
as well as ex caitlyn jenner the current
candidate for governor of california
wrote on the card quote
to the best mother to our children i
could ask for you are an
inspiration happy mother's day kim has
praised her mom to e.t
and for better or worse even hinted she
is set to take over the momager throne
so your mom is the ultimate mom boss yes
and she is a crisis manager puts out
fires
like do you see yourself being that kind
of person that can multitask handle it
or do you still need
no i think i'm like that for all my
sisters
and my brother and everything so i am
more probably like that than my mom
i kind of have like surpassed her on
that part she comes to me
really she needs to put out fires you've
out chris jenner kris jenner yep
wow yep you know what that is the i just
pray
that my my sister my mom doesn't retire
and my sisters don't need a manager
when she retires because i am exhausted